chelsea clinton has made it her mission
to inspire young people through her
books
about notable women the newest book in
her
she persisted series is called she
persisted in sports
american olympians who changed the game
so it tells stories of great female
athletes like
tim tennis champions venus and serena
williams
gold medal gymnast simone biles and
two-time world cup winner that's mia
hamm
chelsea clinton is vice chair of the
clinton foundation she joins us first on
cbs this morning to discuss
chelsea good to see you we're going to
talk about your book in just a second
but first we want to talk about rgb
because i
i saw your um your parents over the
weekend
rbg um so your dad was the one that
appointed her to the supreme court and
your mom was the one i saw an interview
with your mom yesterday
who brought it to your dad's attention
so she was a big favorite in the clinton
household
i'm assuming that you got a chance to
meet her at some point
i did have the chance uh to meet justice
ginsburg
and remember when i was
a little girl when i was 13 and my dad
nominated her
and just how excited i was gail
i mean i had learned about sandra day
o'connor
in you know elementary school as being
the first woman justice of the supreme
court
and i don't think i quite realized there
hadn't been a second until
my father nominated justice ginsburg and
i knew that
my mom had really advocated for her and
just
you know joined so many millions of
americans by being devastated by her
passing on
on friday evening do you think the
decision to replace her the announcement
of who
the president is thinking should wait
until after the election a lot of
chatter about that on both sides
well in 2016 when i was campaigning for
my mom
i spoke i think every event so hundreds
of times about
how important the supreme court
is and how so much of
kind of certainly what i believe is
important whether i'm thinking about
kind of women's rights
civil rights human rights lgbtq rights
or
kind of protecting the environment was
really
kind of going to be at least somewhat
determined by who would be on the court
and i you've said this before justice
scalia's passing and after justice
scalia's passing and
um after justice scalia's passing you
would always say
you know of course his loss was a
devastating uh
personal tragedy for his family and his
loved ones
we still have to have to be focused on
on the supreme court in this election
while
acknowledging and respecting that and i
was accused by the right of
you know dancing on justice scalia's
grave and being disrespectful
and so i have a little bit of whiplash
admittedly over the last
48 hours because kind of the reactions
certainly don't
appear to me to be consistent and i do
believe
that senator mcconnell certainly created
a precedent
when he refused a hearing for judge mark
garland
and and think although i don't expect
him to but certainly think that he
should abide by that yeah there seems to
be a little bit of amnesia in washington
these days we'll wait to see what's
going to happen there but
listen she would have been perfect well
listen in your first book she persisted
you don't have a better role model for
that book than than ruth bader ginsburg
and now you've turned your attention to
sports
number one there were so many things i
didn't know you know i knew some of the
athletes but to hear their backstories
like
wilma rudolph was born premature
prematurely she wore a leg brace yet she
became a champion runner
christy yamaguchi was born with a club
foot she became a champion skater and
then of course venus and serena williams
confronted racism and sexism they
persisted
so your first line in the book says this
it's not easy to be a girl
athlete how come
well i think uh for all of the kind of
women's stories you just
shared and countless others i mean you
know my grandmother gail who you know
was a
huge huge influence on my mom and on me
um spoke a lot about how inspired she'd
been by
two women that i am kind of so honored
to include in she persisted in sports
um dave zaharias and and wilma rudolph
and
she spoke about just how um how much it
inspired her
as a you know kind of uh middle-class
chicago housewife seeing wilma rudolph
so unapologetically
be this fierce athlete and to kind of
represent our country in the olympics
and that she had been a teenage mother
that she had overcome
so many uh challenges in her young life
including multiple kind of illnesses and
sicknesses
and and polio that kind of left her her
legs weekend
um and so i just i grew up surrounded by
these stories of women breaking barriers
including
uh in sports and it's never been easy it
still isn't easy
um and yet we see our women athletes
leading like
uh naomi osaka did so spectacularly at
the u.s open
you know just a few days ago yeah yeah
hey chelsea
tony decouple here uh books matter this
book will matter to
to a lot of readers uh but sports matter
too and that's one of the messages of
this book you played soccer growing up i
think we have a picture of it
if we do let's put it up on camera there
you are
i'm so glad that i could just hear you
and not see you so i'm not like seeing
like the millions of people watching
are seeing my like awkward awkward years
but at least like
in my living room i'm not seeing much
you're welcome chelsea
yeah so the question is i mean thank you
gail thank you thanks for looking out
what did sports mean to you growing up
oh my gosh i loved sports
and i played sports i took ballet and i
just i
found um the camaraderie of being in a
team
kind of learning how to work as a team
kind of learning how to be my best
both to be my best and to be the best
for my team just such like an invaluable
set of lessons um for when i was a kid
and still today and you know when i
think about
you know what i am missing out for my
kids and granted they're they're little
they're one four and five
but you know i i miss kind of the
the camaraderie that you know they're
not having kind of in a classroom right
now
you know that they're not able to have
like you know in a gymnastics class or a
tennis class
or kind of just running around outside
in a park so
i've been thinking a lot about how
important um sports are and how excited
i am for when we're through this moment
which i think is going to last
a lot longer than any of us would hope
or want right that will be part of my
kids lives of the future
agree all i can say is chelsea at least
people wanted you on your on their team
nobody wanted me so i'm still scarred
you can't see it i don't believe that
well it's true i don't believe that
it's true you can't see it but i'm
holding up the book right now
so everybody can see the thing and drew
barrymore who just started her new talk
show last week
announced on the air that she had read
this book to her daughter so i thought
that that was a very sweet shout out to
you
you say it's for young girls and young
people but really people of all ages can
get something out of this book i promise
chelsea
really good to see you really good it's
called thank you so much gail thanks for
having me yeah always
she persisted in sports goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books
we're glad you're on our team